first major convention since the
pandemic began officially kicked off
about 9 30 this morning
it's the world of concrete we hear about
this show all the time this convention
expected to bring in
60 thousand visitors eight news now
reporter sally jaramillo is live outside
the convention center's new west
hall with reaction from those visitors
sally
denise a very exciting day for all of us
here in the las vegas valley even
tourists those who visited
um let me pick it up from here we're
having a trouble with with sally's
signal there but as you can see they had
a ribbon cutting a little earlier this
morning
it's a big day exciting for what really
what it means for travel and for the
industry
richard webster is a visitor from iowa
here's what he had to say
this is my first trip to the world of
cochran yes i normally
visit the other trade shows here con
expo and stuff like that
but we wanted to get out get our face
into the industry and
meet new people in 2020 because of the
pandemic convention attendance was down
about
74 percent webster says with world of
concrete it shows las vegas is really
committed to business and doing it in a
big fashion
with this brand new west hall